Juneteenth is not traditionally American
certainly doesn't unite people and it
doesn't Mark the end of slavery either
in the Emancipation Proclamation or in
the 13th Amendment it doesn't Mark the
end of anything it marks the day that
the mailman made it to some random part
of Texas and told the locals that
Lincoln had freed some of the slaves two
and a half years prior virtually no one
in the country had heard of it until a
few years ago when white liberals
started pretending that it was a really
important date of black people virtually
none of whom had ever heard of it either
and then because the white people
thought the black people really cared
about it everybody started pretending
that it was a thing and now it is a
Federal holiday whatever obscure local
tradition Juneteenth is based on has
little if anything to do with the
current holiday which liberals created
three years ago and named crucially the
Juneteenth National Independence Day why
did they do that in order to replace the
old independence day which is the 4th of
July